chers collègues je n'ai pas un instant
l'intention de faire résonner ici
éloquence à propos de l'abolition ça
m'est arrivé plusieurs fois je dois même
de nombreuses fois mais ça n'est pas le
lieu
et ça n'est pas l'occasion vous êtes des
parlementaires vous êtes des femmes et
des hommes impliqués en politique
connaissant les réalités les difficultés
cette condition et abordant la question
de l'abolition de la peine de mort dans
vos états je voulais essayer de
réinscrire cette question dans la
perspective plus générale du mouvement
vers l'abolition universelle tout à
l'heure le président bayle que je
remercie bien des égards temps de marque
de confiance
révoqué l'abolition intervenues en
france et particulièrement la dernière
nuit de bataille parlementaire au sénat
je m'en souviens fort bien et pour cause
et je me suis approchée au moment où le
vote était inscrit au tableau
électronique de la place qui nous
permettra de le dire du plus grand de
sénateurs c'est-à-dire victor hugo
assurément le plus grand des
abolitionnistes dans la place est au
premier rang
aujourd'hui la ctia genou amis du
communiste et j'ai tenu à mettre ma main
précisément sur cette place sur ce bon
là en me disant c'est fait le voeu est
réalisé l'abolition pure simple
définitif avec un adjectif qui
manquaient pas dans la pensée du go mais
ce jour là c'était universel et par
conséquent le combat fini en france
devait se poursuivre ailleurs alors je
le dis simplement les progrès réalisés
par le mouvement vers l'abolition
universelle
on était plus grand que je l'espérais
même à cette époque et je sais que ce
sentiment était partagé
très franchement nous étions le 35ème et
à la france à abolir la peine de mort je
souligne quand même par modestie gestion
le dernier l'europe occidentale
nous étions 25e états dans le monde à
abolir la peine de mort
je regarde que nous en sommes
aujourd'hui nous abolitionnistes vous
avez 198 état aux nations unies près de
100 sont abolitionnistes de droit
c'est-à-dire autres inscrits la
pollution d'eau leur loi et vous avez
environ 48 50 abolitionnistes de fait
c'est à dire n'ayant pas procédé à des
exécutions depuis dix ans voyez
vous-même de 35 à 148 les trois quarts
aujourd'hui des états des nations unies
sont abolitionnistes et jeu pourquoi je
rappelais le nions pas espérer un tel
résultat
et si l'on veut bien considérer qu'au
delà même des abolitions nationale mais
les pratiques nationales de non
exécution
vous avez des conventions
internationales
alors là le résultat est encore plus
important puisque vous le savez dans les
étapes droit et c'est le cas je pense
pour tous vos états la convention
internationale force juridique
supérieure à la loi nationale
or il existe non seulement des pactes
régionaux l'europe c'est le cas de vente
au col à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme signé je le signale au
sein du conseil de l'europe par 47 sur
48 états de l'europe la peine de mort a
quitté peut-on dire le continent
européens pourtant soulier de temps de
grimm au delà vous avez convention des
nations-unies et particulièrement le
deuxième protocole annexe au pacte sur
les droits civils et politiques
ce sont des engagements j'y reviendrai
pas ce que ça techniquement une
importance extrême dans la bataille pour
l'abolition des engagements
internationaux auxquels les états
leaders ne peuvent plus se dérobe et
ensuite en prenant des lois internes
sauf à quitter l'ensemble international
aux régionales
c'est à dire pratiquement le monde des
droits de l'homme d'où l'importance non
seulement symbolique mais effective de
ces instruments internationaux
j'indique simplement où je le rappelle
ce qui est trop oublié que dans les
juridictions pénales internationales
qu'elles soient haddock ou que ce soit
la cour pénale internationale de la haye
il n'y a jamais de peine de mort je ne
connais pas un magistrat internationale
ou susceptibles de le devenir
qui accepterait de siéger au sein d'une
instance juridictionnelle qui
recouraient à la peine de mort ça le
public ne l'ignorent mais les
professionnels le savent et il s'agit
ici
souvenons nous faisons des pires
criminels qui soit puisque ce sont les
responsables
et souvent les plus hauts responsables
des états qui sont accusés des pires
crimes qu'ils soient et crimes contre
l'humanité et crimes de guerre
les génocides je pourrais continuer la
liste de ces actions atroce donc la
conscience mondiale est aujourd'hui du
côté de l'abolition il faut toujours
vous en
souvenirs parce que cela donne à notre
action non seulement une dimension
morale mais une projection sur l'avenir
les pays abolitionnistes ont tourné la
page des exécutions sanglantes romya oui
mais je dis non le mouvement est
irréversible
il vous suffit de constater qu'en ce qui
concerne les abolitions de droit jamais
jamais a meta important des revenus en
arrière
jamais des hommes politiques et des
femmes politiques n'ont voulu rétablir
la peine de mort partout où elle a été
abolie dans la loi alors à ce stade et
dans ce mouvement
il ya évidemment des zones d'ombré tout
n'est pas que tableau orient dans les
progrès réalisés pour l'abolition et son
nombre à vous les connaissez comme moi
la liste des états qui retiennent la
peine de mort est la pratique est
importante et significative en tête
vous avez évidemment racing avec un
tempérament qu'il faut prendre en compte
je parlerai pas du nouveau
abolitionniste chinoise conférence sur
le riche univers sale mais il existait
il ya de plus en plus d'avocats et
d'universitaires qui y participent
mais ce que j'entends marqué parce que
ceux ci concernent directement les
travaux qui sont les vôtres c'est que
ensuite de la chine et attention
proportionnellement à leur population
bord en plus que la chine d'autres états
exécute
je laisse de côté le cas particulier si
significatif d etats unis grandes
démocraties vieille république ayant
comme on le sait un recours aisé au port
d'armes et à ses conséquences
on dit que les états unis en effet
conserve non seulement les textes
mais l'usager la peine de mort
parfaitement exact pour leur compte
je marque quand même que le mouvement
aux etats-unis pour l'abolition de la
peine de mort n'a cessé de progresser
dans les dix dernières années et que à
cet égard on doit relever que non
seulement le nombre de condamnations à
la peine de mort a diminué de moitié en
dix ans dans des exécutions en plus mais
que six états et parmi les plus
importants des états unis ont rejoint
les douze qui depuis toujours et est
abolitionniste les états unis ce n'est
pas un bloc c'est une fédération d'états
en ce qui concerne le droit pénal
mosaïque de législation et vous avez un
mouvement qui va s'accroissant vers
l'abolition je citerai dans les
dernières années et ça n'est pas des
petits et à l'état de new york où l'état
de l'illinois chicago dont le président
obama est issu donc en ce qui concerne
états unis une exception humiliante
honteuse même s'agissant de la peine de
mort le dire que ce sont les états du
sud des états unis
et on connaît leur histoire
esclavagistes qui pratiquent encore la
peine de mort et parmi eux le texas mais
c'est pas le coeur de l'observation
d'aujourd'hui et juge à cet égard je
serai aussi lucide et précis possible
lorsque vous regardez la carte des états
qui pratiquent la peine de mort vous
constatez que dans l'ensemble de la
région laquelle aujourd'hui nous
intéressons et des roses est
l'expression la plus conscients et les
consciences les plus vigilante la région
moyen orient et afrique du nord
là le nombre d'exécutions et de
condamnations à mort demeurent très
important très important nous avons en
2012 dans six pays seulement 550 cette
exécution officiellement recensés
et quand vous comparez ces chiffres état
par état et je prends en particulier le
cas des en tête de l'iran suivis
aujourd'hui de l'irak après le pakistan
puis ensuite l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats des émirats arabes unis mais
surtout pour l'irak et l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite
vous êtes au delà proportionnellement du
nombre des exécutions en chine par
centaines de milliers d'habitants c'est
à dire qu'on n'utilise plus la peine de
mort dans ces états du moyen-orient que
on le fait en chine pour ne pas parler
des états unis bien sûr
alors vous vous interrogez mais pourquoi
et quand vous allez plus loin que
l'interrogation quand vous parlez de le
dire ici je parle attendent amis issus
de ces régions et particulièrement du
maghreb je pense que la raison profonde
qui crée cette espèce de barrières au
sein d'êta qui n'ont pas de raison
particulière d'y souscrire au contraire
tiens tu as un phénomène et ce phénomène
je le dis clairement si que la
législation de ces états la législation
terrestre celle de la cité pas la
religion pas la législation religieuse
et bien inévitablement retomber devant
une difficulté majeure
ce que je dis il faut une certaine dose
de courage et de confiance dans ses
auditeurs pour le
mais quand j'en vois où quand j'entends
des amis au magistrat égyptiens dans
leur décision
comme dans leurs confidences expliqué
que la législation en matière de droits
de l'homme est un bienfait de dieu mais
qu'à partir de ce moment là il faut
interpréter la législation selon les
canons de la religion de dieu qui nous
les a donnés je me dis obstacles et la
laïcité qui n'est pas je me ne cesse de
le rappeler
la laïcité n'est pas l'adversaire de
religion elle garantit à chacun la libre
pratique de sa confession
elle assume la liberté religieuse et la
liberté de conviction elle n'est pas à
la caricature odieuse qu'on leur donne à
des fins souvent de maintien de son
pouvoir
et bien la laïcité ici et la voie
ouverte sinon la condition nécessaire
pour obtenir l'abolition de la peine de
mort
je le dis clairement je suis une très
vieille moustache que ces combats et
combien une fois mes amis m'ont dit oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce comme ça qu'est
ce que tu veux qu'est ce que tu veux si
les abolissant la peine de mort je parle
de pays abolitionnistes de fait les
signaux abolition peine de mort en droit
et bien le monde politique étant ce
qu'il est les combats politiques étant
ce qu'ils sont impitoyables nous savons
qu'ils viendraient deraa
ils se prétendent de bons musulmans mais
regardez ils ont violé la charia et on
sortirait immédiatement les textes et
les conséquences politiques seraient
désastreuses bien au delà de la vente
âge politique et morale que nous pouvons
espérer de l'abolition
c'est un propos terribles parce que ça
veut dire
comme au pakistan que on a une grille de
constitutionnalité qui nous vient du
ciel
moi je respecte toutes les religions
je n'ai pas besoin de dire ici nice à
laquelle j'appartiens ni le d'inciter de
man adhésion ça regarde chacun mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que d'entendre ce
propos tenus par d'éminents esprit de
grandes zones d'état que je respecte que
je peux le cacher très grande conscience
de ce qu'est ce que tu veux qu'est ce
que vous voulez on veut tous n'aime pas
perdre ce que nous sommes en train de
réaliser comme progrès vers la liberté
et la démocratie
simplement en faisant passer la pratique
de l'abolition dans un texte loi c sera
trop cher payé pour avoir longtemps vécu
dans ces assemblées je sais que ce n'est
pas un discours indifférent mais la
demeure inscrit le problème car quand je
regarde la liste de ces pays je laisse
de côté
virant aujourd'hui je n'hésite pas à le
dire
hélas hélas à ce point-ci grand peuple
terre de fanatisme
je laisse de côté l'irak qui depuis sa
décomposition à la suite de l'agression
américaine est devenue une terre
d'exécution à un niveau supérieur encore
père capita aux autres mais je regarde
les pays les plus intégristes arabie
saoudite
on sait ce qu'on punit nord en arabie
saoudite le blasphème
la post asie ce sont des catégories
juridiques et pour ça on est mis à mort
et on est mis à mort non seulement du
côté des hommes mais du côté des femmes
et en pratiquant la lapidation biblique
voilà la réalité alors la réponse est je
parle ici deux responsables de ces pays
est toujours la réponse religieuse
nous avons une religion qui est une
religion qui doit gouverner l'état et
dans les prescriptions de cette religion
il y à la mise à mort de telle coupable
pour telle infraction partir de là un
homme comme moi mais tous nos amis nous
sommes réduits au silence
pour une raison simple quelle qualité
est-ce que nous pouvons avoir pour
interpréter la loi religieuse
aucune qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
croire que je la moindre autorité pour
interpréter la charia
par ailleurs je le dis franchement que
je me qualités pour interpréter l'ancien
et le nouveau testament taux plus
intéressante il mais je ne juge pas apte
à l'interpréter
alors quand il s'agit de ce qui devient
des catégories religieuse portée
effective
je viens pont oui c'est pas moi de
répondre c'est à vous ce discours là
c'est celui de cette terre mais si on
veut placer le discours au ciel alors le
dialogue devient difficile il y avait
pays musulmans et ils existent et sont
plus nombreux qu'on le pense communément
si on t'a boli je relève au passage que
la turquie est laïque
la jolie que le sénégal est une
république laïque est abolie et je
pourrais continuer sont des musulmans
donc la véritable réponse c'est à vous
de la porte et nous pouvons que vous
soutenir applaudir mais la parole qui
est la nôtre elle s'arrête parce que
vous n'avez pas la qualité qui vend ce
cercle à vous permet de parler avec
autorité
vous veillez rabat et regardez l'exemple
de tous les pays abolitionnistes jamais
la criminalité sanglante a augmenté les
immenses davantage l'abolition en ce qui
concerne la justice échapper à la
justice sociale à la pauvreté à
l'inégalité au racisme qui empoisonne le
monde
la pratique de la peine de mort tout ça
ce sont des avantages universel mais si
on place d'ilcu sion au niveau que
j'évoquais nous sommes-nous laïque
réduit au silence
et comme le silence permet pas de faire
naître le progrès pour l'abolition
il n'y a qu'une solution c'est que ce
combat là deviennent le vôtre et que ce
soit comme l'ont d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises fait je salue vieil saison là
dessus sont contre la peine de mort vous
suscite y est du côté de vos meilleurs
interprètes des discussions pour savoir
qu'elle est l'exacte portée car sur ce
point j'ai entendu des avis
contradictoires de docteur en théologie
musulmane meilleure interprétation ou
les interprétations possibles de la loi
religieuse
vous savez dans ce domaine depuis des
siècles et des siècles est partout d'où
existe des religions révélées
l'imagination de l'internet est immense
sans limite
je ne sache pas que si on prend les
textes de l'ancien et du nouveau
testament la peine de mort n'y soit pas
inscrite la somme peuple libérien
beaucoup grâce à cet effort
d'interprétation
non pas en s'attendent à ce que soient
proférées le propos la peine de mort est
interdite par la loi religieuse mais
comme je lé entendu ailleurs et à la
peine de mort possible
je n'ai pas forcé elle devient une
question de gouvernement des corps pas
de gouvernement des âmes
elle s'inscrit ici sur cette terre
les théologiens dirait hic est donc ici
et maintenant
quant aux comptes que nous aurons à
rendre aux créateurs cela se passera
quand il le voudra et sont les critères
là haut qu'il aura lui-même défini mais
sur cette terre mes amis c'est la loi
humaine des régies des êtres humains
et quand on exécute des êtres humains
quand on lapide qu'on étrangle kong à ce
qu'on pique au biotine compan ce sont
des êtres humains
il relève à cet instant et leur vie de
la loi de ce monde et je vous demande je
dirai pas ce que je dirais presque j'ai
supplié de rappeler que ce n'est pas ici
que des hommes doivent se permettent sur
cette terre de se dire dépositaire de la
parole divine pour tuer des femmes et
des hommes
c'était votre tâche ne sera pas facile
j'en suis convaincu que modestement ce
cas nous fera ce qu'il pourra comme il
pourra pour vous aider mais que c'est à
vous seul que revient en définitive
lourd fardeau ensuite l'immense joie
d'avoir mis un terme à justice et tu ici
bas et rappelez-vous qui tue ici bas
dans les états dans laïque aux yeux au
nom de dieu qui tuent au nom de dieu
merci
merci merci cher robert badinter merci
pour votre rôle majeur il est
remplaçable dans ce beau combat je passe
maintenant la parole à monsieur emmanuel
maistre qui est secrétaire général de
ensemble contre la peine de mort
monsieur le président cher robert
badinter
monsieur le ministre cheikh antoinette
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
d'algérie d'égypte d'irak de jordanie de
libye du liban du maroc de mauritanie
des territoires palestiniens de tunisie
et de france mesdames et messieurs les
militants au nom de l'association
ensemble contre la peine de mort
co organisateur de cet événement
international
je suis heureux et fier de vous
accueillir pour ce premier séminaire
parlementaire sur la peine de mort dans
la région afrique du nord et
moyen-orient
la diversité des pays représentés ici
durant ces deux jours dans l'enceinte du
parlement français montre combien le
combat pour l'abolition de la peine de
mort est une préoccupation qui touche
l'ensemble des sociétés du nord comme du
sud
l'ensemble des parlements de la planète
et en particulier également ceux du
monde arabe
parce que l'abolition et la base de
développement de toute société pacifiée
et respectueuse des droits fondamentaux
des individus
son combat est universelle et traverse
l'ensemble des chambres parlementaires
depuis son origine
ensemble contre la peine de mort a
toujours oeuvré à mobiliser les
parlementaires pour faire avancer la
cause de l'abolition universelle pour
ensemble contre la peine de mort
les parlementaires sont la clé de voûte
de l'abolition
c'est avec eux avec leur conscience avec
leur éthique
que l'abolition voit le jour c'est leur
vote qui permet l'avènement d'une
abolition fruit d'une lutte acharnée de
la société civile voire de la société
dans son ensemble et ce vote
porté par le parlementaire insufflé par
l'intérêt fondamental et général pour la
société dépasse balles et les clivages
partisans
j'en veux pour preuve l'adoption ici
même dans ce palais du luxembourg
cette assemblée du sénat alors à droite
l'adoption à une large majorité le 30
septembre 1981 de la loi abolissant la
peine de mort en france à l'occasion du
premier congrès mondial contre la peine
de mort de strasbourg en 2001 le
président de l'assemblée nationale cet
immense abolitionniste qu'est le
regretté raymond forni a lancé un appel
des présidents de parlement contre la
peine de mort
à l'époque les présidents des parlements
de belgique du chili de côte d'ivoire de
grèce d'espagne de france du cambodge
d'italie de malte des pays-bas
d'autriche du portugal et d'ukraine ont
signé cet appel également porté par le
parlement européen et l'assemblée
parlementaire du conseil de l'europe
depuis 2001 ils sont des dizaines de
parlement à travers le monde à avoir
voté l'abolition de la peine de mort
dans un mouvement sans précédent vers
l'abolition universelle
aujourd'hui c'est aux parlementaires
d'afrique du nord et du moyen-orient que
nous voulons dire oui l'abolition
universelle est possible dans le
prolongement du 5e congrès mondial
contre la peine de mort de madrid qui a
été marquée par une présence sans
précédent de parlementaires de pays
rétentionnistes en provenance des
régions d'afrique du nord et du
moyen-orient d'afrique centrale
d'afrique de l'est et d'asie
dans le prolongement de cette
mobilisation
nous voulons dire et redire
parlementaire abolitionniste de tous
pays unissez vous
tous ensemble abolitionnistes unissons
nous j'ai lu l'honneur lors de ce même
5e congrès mondial à madrid de
participer à la rédaction de l'appel des
parlementaires marocains à la création
de réseaux nationaux de parlementaires
contre la peine de mort à rabat fait
unique dans un pays condamnant toujours
à la peine capitale
pas moins de 208 parlementaires de la
chambre des représentants et de la
chambre des conseillers
toutes tendances politiques confondues à
l'exception notable du parti islamiste
au pouvoir
208 parlementaires se sont fédérées
depuis février 2013 dans un réseau
contre la peine de mort leur objectif et
je les cite de prendre des initiatives
législatives visant à l'abolition de la
peine de mort visant à une réforme
pénale profonde
inspiré des droits humains prenant la
réinsertion et la resocialisation des
condamnés visant à la ratification du
deuxième protocole facultatif du pacte
international des droits civils et
politiques se rapportant à l'abolition
de la peine de mort et visant enfin à
l'annoncé officielle d'un moratoire sur
les exécutions
ce réseau constitue pour nous tous
désormais un nouvel acteur majeur du
mouvement abolitionniste marocain et
mondial un acteur complémentaire de la
société civile l'appel qu'ils ont lancée
à madrid invite les parlementaires des
pays rétentionnistes de la région et du
monde entier à s'inspirer de cette
initiative et à s'engager dans cette
voie
faire naître une voix abolitionnistes
dans chaque parlement pour travailler
avec les acteurs de la société civile à
l'avènement de l'abolition notre
séminaire veut amplifier cet appel et
permettre aux députés abolitionniste des
pays de la région aux parlementaires
abolitionniste des pays de la région
d'échanger sur leurs pratiques et leurs
stratégies et d'organiser un soutien
régional et international à leur action
je fais le pari qu au lendemain de ces
deux jours de rencontres
mouvement abolitionniste sortira encore
renforcé et que nos échanges et travaux
seront une pierre supplémentaire dans la
construction du mur de l'abolition
universelle
je fais le voeu que nos travaux
permettront de faire avancer l'abolition
dans une des rares zones du monde où
elle marque le pas c'est peu de le dire
l'afrique du nord et le moyen-orient au
nom d'ensemble contre la peine de mort
je tiens à vous remercier tous
parlementaires et représentants de la
société civile et des médias de votre
présence nombreuse ici pour ces deux
jours alors que demain 10 octobre
nous célèbrerons la 11e journée mondiale
contre la peine de mort qui sous l'égide
de la coalition mondiale contre la peine
de mort verra dans le monde entier
fleurir des centaines d'initiatives
abolitionnistes je veux aussi remercier
chaleureusement le réseau marocain des
parlementaires contre la peine de mort
et la coalition marocaine contre la
peine de mort pour leur engagement et
leur confiance
permettez-moi encore de remercier nos
hôtes